[Applause]
[Music]
in the next few decades the world as we
know it will change a lot this will of
course bring many opportunities but also
many challenges more precisely most
developed countries are facing such a
large threat that their response may
determine in economic political and
social terms which countries succeed and
which fail folks I'm talking about
population ageing of the demographic
pyramids 180 degree turn
yeah I'm sure this isn't news to you
most of you have probably already heard
about this subject however have you
stopped to think about the processes
consequences are your governments doing
something about it have they come up
with something like a contingency plan
to face the risks that lie ahead are
listen up
the world facing a new stage in about a
hundred years our world has changed a
lot it has changed so much that if we
got a time machine say some sort of
special DeLorean and travelled back two
or three centuries for a season sooner
rather than later most of us if not all
of us would want to go back home really
really fast we'd be missing loads of
things would be horrified by the day to
day we'd be forced to work intensely
hard and just to survive and would be
afraid of getting sick because we might
die and we might not even be able to eat
but let's stay on topic here
the fact is that at the end of the 19th
century the world's population surpassed
the 1.5 billion person barrier
[Music]
yet only a hundred years later during
the 20th century the world's population
is multiplied by four and surpassed six
billion people and of course considering
the enormous speed with which the world
population grew we can't be surprised by
the fact that many experts began to
worry about overpopulation and do you
not think that this was just a thing
among mediocre experts scientists and
politicians
in 1974 a report by the Secretary of
State Henry Kissinger urged Richard
Nixon's government to consider birth
control in countries such as Brazil
India Mexico Colombia Ethiopia and
Thailand as a top priority according to
the report the demographic explosion
that was taking place posed a serious
threat to the very security of the
United States with so many people
consuming resources Kissinger thought we
were heading towards a world of scarcity
and fierce struggles for resources have
you noticed how Malthusian arguments
come up again and again even though they
never actually happen the fact is that
what guys like Kissinger tried to think
about how to control the world's
population and influence their decisions
a change was already taking place such a
huge change that it would turn an
entirely new point in the debate
[Music]
in the last 50 years world fertility has
halved so much so that nowadays Western
governments no longer think about
overpopulation but rather about aging
today European countries and even the
United States tend to lose native
inhabitants check this out in Germany
for example since 1972 there have been 5
million more deaths than births however
the most extreme case has been that of
Russia where in just 20 years between
1991 and 2011 there were thirteen point
one three more deaths than there were
births future projections show that in
the next 50 years Europe's native
population will decrease by around a
hundred million people and not just that
the other effect of this entire process
is that the world's population
especially that of the most developed
countries is aging at full speed and
that my friends
it's posing many many challenges
pensions health care expenses dependents
and the question is now how on earth can
we finance this gigantic expense to give
you an idea of what we're talking about
here is estimated that in many European
countries the percentage of the
population over 65 years old will be
around 40 percent by 2050 and one of
those most affected countries is
actually Spain so listen up
a country of retired people
here's an exercise for you let's assume
that fertility in Spain and the European
Union remains within the rates that
they've had since the year 2000 and that
in addition no immigrants arrive you
want to know what's going to happen well
check out the following graph as you can
see if your population aged between 18
and 40 years which is the population
that works the most in the population
has the most children that's going to
take a huge dip of course the number of
inhabitants just a decade later that
follow the same trend folks Spain is one
of the countries that's beginning to
suffer the most from this demographic
crisis the demographic crisis is getting
worse
Spain suffers its biggest population
loss in 2017 if we take a look at the
average number of children per women we
can truly understand what's going on
here
[Music]
[Applause]
and this is taking into account that the
arrival of immigrants in the last 20
years has boosted birth rates nowadays
23% of all children born in Spain almost
one in four have a foreign mother
but perhaps the most important data to
predict what's going to happen will come
from looking at how the number of people
of working age will evolve they after
all other ones who generate the vast
majority of resources both public and
private well if we assume that there's
no emigration in just 30 years the
working age Spanish population would
decrease by 10 million people and
according to the projections of the
Institute of statistics of the
government of Spain Spaniards will face
this panorama by 2050 19 million people
of working age of whom of course not a
whorl work and almost 22 million
children and retirees that is the
dependent population would be greater
than the working age population now
we're talking about Spain specifically
here but this scenario is very familiar
to most developed countries as you can
imagine all of this has many
consequences the consequences
in recent times there's been a lot of
talk about the risk of automation but
perhaps the most imminent risk that
develops countries have to face is their
quick
aging process at the end of the day it's
clear that an aging population has
several consequences for one it's
foreseeable that if nothing changes
public spending will skyrocket to pay
pensions health care expenses assistance
and care for the elderly among many
other things
pension spending increases by 50 percent
in Spain in ten years and no doubt this
will be very clear to politicians the
hegemony of retired voters will be
overwhelming it's simply a matter of
votes but at the same time as we've seen
there are going to be a few are working
age people so the question is how on
earth are we going to pay for this huge
expense will the already high taxes be
raised even further damaging the
competitiveness of countries with as
many economic problems as Spain or
perhaps Italy well the reality is that's
a recipe that just doesn't work now at
this point I think we need to answer a
mandatory question and that's well what
the hell can we do
we need a plan I know politicians don't
usually like to think about the future
especially future problems probably goes
a little something like this what I need
to think about problems that will happen
in twenty years from now and risk losing
votes no no no no no no no let someone
else take care of that well if we don't
want to see headlines like this develops
countries are going to need a plan
Japan's Finance Minister tells elderly
they should hurry up and die to help
reduce country's rising welfare bill the
time to make decisions is now in
countries that decide to look the other
way and do nothing will face many many
problems in the future you see lately
here on visual politic we've talked a
lot about immigration well experience
tells us that this is a good way to stop
population aging and by time
to make new reforms as Australia Hong
Kong New Zealand and Singapore have
shown integration can soften the blow
from rapid aging chung-yong read
director of the asia-pacific Department
at the International Monetary Fund yes
despite many politicians discourse the
truth is that developed countries will
need many people to arrive from abroad
so folks instead of thinking about
building walls and closing borders it
would be much more advisable to start a
system that manages to attract people
from outside in an orderly fashion and
facilitates their integration but of
course that's not all
as public pension systems will almost
certainly become much less generous
because they won't have as much of a
budget governments should also be
promoting saving both from the
governments themselves and from families
is any Spanish political party warning
citizens of the neck servile cut in
their pensions no they're all silent
about our true future giving a false
impression that one doesn't need to save
to guarantee a fairly dignified
retirement Kwan Rahman REO economist and
director of the juan de mariana
institute and along with all this of
course governments should promote
policies that attract companies that
promote entrepreneurship and above all
that favor productivity investment in
machines and technology and in research
and developments yes I think robots are
actually going to greatly help with this
problem
[Music]
unfortunately in many of the affected
countries including Spain nothing is
being done and finally before we finish
I'd like to throw out an idea see the
effect of aging is accompanied by a
longevity effect allow me to explain
this thanks to medical advances better
nutrition and higher quality of life
mortality rates for all ages have
decreased that is people are younger for
longer see in the United States for
example a 75 year olds person has the
same mortality rate today as a 65 year
old person had in the 1950s in Japan 80
is the new 65 and also thanks to medical
and technological advances this
evolution it continues to grow and grow
which the humanity is fantastic
therefore if people have longer ins more
productive life wouldn't it be wise to
encourage them to continue working for
longer I mean even partially or in more
comfortable roles and that's where I'm
gonna leave today's video but now it's
your turn would you be in favor of
increasing your country's retirement age
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also don't forget to check out
our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast he provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine or soaked
this channel as always it's possible
because of our patrons on patreon please
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always see in
the next video
[Music]